[موسيقى]
دعنا نتحدث عن السيد أوبراين نفسه،
سلوكه كما يعرف الجميع هنا
في آخر مرة كان لدينا فيها لقاء
العودة إلى الأمام، أقدر أنك
ستلتقي اليوم، الأمر مختلف تمامًا ولكن
بعدك  لقد تركت هنا، لقد كنت
متحمسًا جدًا بشأن لوحة المفاتيح، وفي الواقع
قمت بالتغريد في وجهي مرة واحدة واثنتين و3 و4 خمس مرات
واسمحوا لي أن أقرأ ما قاله الأخير، لقد
قال الرئيس التنفيذي الجشع الذي يتظاهر
بأنه عصامي لذا، أتمنى لو كنت في
الشاحنة  معي عندما كنت أقوم ببناء
شركة السباكة الخاصة بي بنفسي وكانت زوجتي
تدير المكتب لأنني بالتأكيد
أتذكر العمل الجاد لساعات طويلة
ويتظاهر وكأنه عصامي، كما كان دائمًا المحتال
المهرج دائمًا
سيترك قانون الرجل القوي و  جلسات
استماع في مجلس الشيوخ، أنت تعرف أين
تجدني في أي مكان وفي أي
وقت، يا سيدي كاوبوي، هذا هو الوقت المناسب، هذا هو
المكان الذي تريد أن تتحدث فيه، يمكننا أن
نكون مع بالغين موافقين، يمكننا إنهاء الأمر
هنا، حسنًا، هذا جيد، مثالي، تريد
أن تفعل ذلك الآن.  أحب أن أفعل ذلك الآن،
حسنًا، قف مؤخرتك ثم قف
مؤخرتك أوه، توقف، هذا هو
الحل الخاص بك كل لا، لا، اجلس، اجلس،
لا، أنت عضو في
مجلس الشيوخ الأمريكي، اجلس حسنًا، اجلس من فضلك،
حسنًا  هل يمكنني الرد،
إذا لم نتمكن من ذلك، لا لدي أنا آسف، سيكون
لديك وقتك، حسنًا، هل يمكنني
الرد أوه لا، لا يمكنك، هذه جلسة
استماع والله يعلم أن
الشعب الأمريكي لديه ما يكفي من ازدراء
الكونجرس  دعنا لا
نتحدث، أنا لا أحبك لأنك
وصفت نفسك للتو، أمسك به، لديك
الميكروفون، لديك الوقت لبيانك،
فلنفعل ذلك لأنني
تحديتك وقبلت
تحديك والتزمت الصمت،
لا، لم أذهب  لقد كنت هادئًا، لقد تحديتني
في مباراة قفص وأتصرف
مثل طفل في المدرسة يبلغ من العمر 12 عامًا،
عذرًا، لا عذرًا، لدي M سأقول إنني
سأقول بشكل دقيق، لدي الميكروفون،
لديك أسئلة حول أي
قضايا اقتصادية  أي شيء قاله،
نحن لسنا هنا للحديث عن
الاعتداء الجسدي الذي جلبته، نحن لا نتحدث
عنه بالطبع واسمحوا لي أن أظهر
لك سمعه لأنني أريد أن أريد
فضح هذا السفاح لمن هو أنت
لا تشير إلي أن هذا عدم احترام، أنا
لا أهتم باحترامك على الإطلاق، أنا
أحترمني،
لا، أنت من أكثر الأشخاص تصرفًا، من فضلك
حسنًا، هذا عذر لي، هذه
جلسة استماع لمناقشة القضايا الاقتصادية